it's football sunday the buffalo bills
are at the miami dolphins and we're here
to find out if gambling and playing
fantasy football is worth it let's talk
money all we talk is money all we talk
is money all we talk is money all we
talk is money all we talk is money
all we talk is money who do you like
today who do you like today dolphins
[ __ ] dolphins okay all right i think
the bill's by 31 the bill is by a
billion it's gonna be the miami dolphins
500 to six
we're going to win duh no score
you've ever gambled on do you gamble or
play fantasy football at all
where's my wife we gamble yeah we'd
always gamble i don't gamble because i
have an addiction problem really i plead
the fifth i don't have any money do you
think it's a colossal waste of time or
is it a money thing it's a money thing
do you have five bucks on you i probably
out of football ever no no i see
football no always always what's the
most you've ever gambled on a game i
like how you look around so you're your
woman don't you don't see that i look
it's fifty dollars oh two hundred i
don't want to disclose that guy
a 100 150 150 700 okay did you win or
lose i lost and then what'd you do after
that i cried
what do you love about gambling i love
the whole aspect of it i love
winning and what are you it's the
feeling
there's no other way to go about it oh i
like that journey that like risk taking
man it's winning the thrill what do you
hate about gambling losing i don't hate
anymore gambling nothing i lose money
all the time did i lose what do i hate
yes players getting hurt and messing up
my freaking fantasy you always mess it
up losing of course obviously the money
that i lose lose it buddy final piece of
advice for the people at home
gambling playing fantasy football what
do you want to let them to know you know
what sometimes you lose sometimes you
win but when you win is twice as better
than when you lose oh i love that play
play so you win baby bills by a billion
do your research have some money luck
lady luck you got to be on your side you
want to lose you still have fun on it
you bet what many that you have and you
want to bet on you gotta gable take a
risk life is short do it it's worth it
it's a way of life it's worth it yes it
is tell us why if your profitability
it's worth it stop it
you're just losing money you're just
losing money go to the bar it's worth it
cause the money baby the money that's
what it is it's all a lot of money baby
don't gamble say your money baby
so as you can see i interviewed a lot of
people that love gambling and enjoy
playing fantasy football but here's my
two cents i used to spend every sunday
of my life playing fantasy football
sitting on the couch watching football
wasting a lot of time to win very little
money so here's my advice to you rather
than spending all that time sitting
around playing fantasy football invest
your time wisely and do something that
is more productive use of your time save
that time and save that money all we
talk is money all we talk is money all
we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
[Music]